[Music]
the snow that once capped the andes
mountains above chile's capital and
central valley is conspicuously absent
for centuries melting ice nourished
rivers below
400 kilometers to the north la paloma
south america's largest irrigation
reservoir has only 20 percent left of
the water that once made this valley
flourish
further north the deficit is 100
13 years of relentless drought the
longest on record is transforming chile
and not for the better
we're standing on the river which we
depend on to water our crops but look at
the state it's in it used to carry loads
of water but it's all dried up this year
it practically didn't rain at all
mr echeverria and his sole employee are
trying to revive the vines that survived
last year's dismal harvest
there's years of work sacrifice and
investment here and it's sad to see our
livelihood and that of so many families
lost i used to have 50 workers here at
this time of year and that source of
employment is now gone
small farmers and multi-billion dollar
agricultural exporters alike are
suffering the consequences of a drought
that the government believes is here to
stay la
the drought is no longer an emergency
it's turned into a structural change
we need to establish a different
relationship with water because it's
become a scarce resource
authorities and scientists blame global
warming for the rapid depletion of
chile's patagonian glaciers
the drastic reduction of rainfall and
the sustained increase in temperatures
the once mediterranean climate of
central and south central chile is
rapidly mimicking a desert there's far
less water and at the same time a much
greater demand for agriculture the big
dilemma of course is what to do about it
this week the government launched a
nationwide water saving campaign that
warns there are only two options
conserve it or there will be none left
but experts in resource sustainability
say the key is better water
the efficient use of the water we have
modernization of production processes
technology reusing water producing more
with less water and on less land are all
crucial
many rural communities that have lost
everything are selling their land and
migrating to cities
but experts insist that if taken
seriously science technology and social
discipline can establish a new and more
realistic relationship with an element
that only 20 years ago seemed infinite
lucia newman al jazeera central chile